IT'S TIME TO PLAY "YOU NEWS, YOU
LOSE."
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
WITH A CONSTANTLY UPDATING
STREAM OF DIGITAL INFORMATION AT
OUR FINGERTIPS AT ALL TIMES, IS
TV NEWS EVEN NECESSARY ANYMORE?
WELL, I SAY A RESOUNDING YES!
NOT BECAUSE IT'S THE BEST WAY TO
GET INFORMATION, BUT BECAUSE
IT'S FUN TO LAUGH AT THEIR DUMB,
OUT-OF-CONTEXT CAPTIONS
SOMETIMES.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A BAFFLING
NEWS HEADLINE AND FOR 250
POINTS-- AND PLEASE DO YOUR BEST
ANCHOR VOICE WHEN YOU DO THIS--
PLEASE GIVE ME A LINE FROM THAT
STORY.
FIRST ONE, "MAN WRESTLES SHARK,
LOSES JOB."
>> THE MAN SAID, "THANKS, OBAMA,
THAT'S WHAT YOU GET FOR GOING
SOFT ON SHARK IMMIGRATION."
>> CHRIS: POINTS. SHARK HERO
FIRED FOR TRAVELING ON SICK
LEAVE.
>>SHARK HERO!
SHARK HERO!
♪ HE'S THE HERO OF THE SHARKS ♪
IS HE A HERO FOR THE SHARK--
>> I WAS PICTURING GUITAR HERO,
LIKE HE'S PLAYING A SHARK.
>> IT'S LIKE A SHARK GUITAR.
>> SHARK GUITAR.
>> OH,.
>> CHRIS: KUMAIL.
>> IN RUSSIA, SHARK WRESTLE JOB,
LOSE MAN.
>> CHRIS: ANOTHER POINT.
>> I GET IT.
I GET IT.
( APPLAUSE )
"SANTA IMPERSONATOR ASKED TO
TONE IT DOWN."
KUMAIL.
>> OH, WHAT A CREEPY MAN.
SANTA IMPERSONATOR
ASKED TO TONE IT DOWN--DURING A
RECENT VISIT TO MECCA.
( BLEEP ).
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NEXT: THIS WOMAN IS "AWAITING
PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S ARRIVAL IN ME!"
( APPLAUSE )
JONAH.
>> SOURCES SAY HIS FINGERS WILL
ARRIVE FIRST.
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
EMILY.
>> TO BE CLEAR, M.E. IS THE
ABBREVIATION FOR THE STATE OF
MAINE, WHICH IS WHERE THE
PRESIDENT WILL ( BLEEP ) ME.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
KUMAIL.
>> PRESIDENT INSISTS YOU CAN'T
GET PREGNANT.
WE'RE IN A HOT TUB!
>> THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S ACTUALLY TRUE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE, "HAVE A
GREAT DAY!"
EMILY.
>> CBS WANTS TO REMIND YOU THE
WORLD IS A SQUALID PIT SO BURN
IT. BURN IT ALL TO THE ( BLEEP )
GROUND.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
JONAH.
>> JUST A REMINDER, I STILL HATE
MY EX-WIFE.
( APPLAUSE )
>> YOU TOOK EVERYTHING!
YOU TOOK EVERYTHING!
LAST ONE:
"WHITE HOUSE: OBAMA CAN'T GO
BACK IN TIME."
>> UNLESS HE CAN GET THE
MOTORCADE UP TO 88 MILES PER
HOUR.